researchers in australia have identified
and mapped more than 380 suspected
detention facilities in xinjiang
that northwestern part of china where
the government has interned hundreds of
thousands possibly more than a million
muslim minorities including the uyghurs
that's 100 more facilities than
previously known
and they used satellite images to build
their database
one trend has stood out the communist
party is building
more high security prisons and
decommissioning
the lower security ones in other words
in the last three years
they've doubled down on this crackdown
despite
growing international pressure and
what's happening
directly contradicts beijing's narrative
china first tried to deny the existence
of camps
then it said most people in there have
returned home and now with these latest
revelations
this is what the chinese foreign
ministry said
xinjiang is
so-called detention camps have never
existed in xinjiang
we have repeatedly responded to various
china-related reports
fabricated by the australian strategic
policy institute
joining us is nathan rooster of the
australian strategic policy institute
the think tank that made these
discoveries and tracked these changes
nathan tell us more about what you found
hey melissa thanks for having me um
basically what we've found
is an extensive detention regime that
stretches
across the whole of xinjiang and is very
enduring and very permanent in its
nature we found that
60 camps in the last year or so have
seen considerable construction
and there are a number that have still
sort of under construction today
and in the last few hours you guys have
also released some new information about
the systemic destruction of mosques
there as well tell me more about that
yeah so we actually wanted to focus and
try to get a quantified number of how
many
an estimate at least of how many mosques
in xinjiang have been destroyed under
this policy
so we set out to find as many mosques as
we could
as many mosques as possible before 2017.
as a part of this we found about
600 mosques of varying across xinjiang
and of all of those we sort of looked at
them and assessed their current
condition
and we found that about a third of them
had been demolished and about a third of
them had been damaged
so in all the in all we found that about
16 000 mosques in xinjiang had either
been damaged
or destroyed as part of this systematic
campaign of cultural eurasia
in xinjiang that has mostly been
launched since 2017.
now looking through these satellite
images spending hours trying to
determine whether what you're seeing is
a place that's meant to imprison people
or not
what goes through your mind and how do
you feel
so a lot of it honestly is just scouring
satellite imagery
for hours and hours so for example
at the start of this project we had
about 100 facilities that we knew from
primary source evidence
which is journalists or construction
tenders
were actually um detention facilities
and so
looking at that we built an idea of what
these facilities looked like we saw the
four different tiers
the four different levels of
securitization and the
the re-education camps the detention
centers and the prisons
following that with that sort of
knowledge in hand we were able to just
scour a satellite scour satellite
imagery for hours and hours
and sort of pick out on a map all the
facilities that looked
and basically matched this profile so we
were aided in that for example
by looking at satellite light the night
satellite imagery that
showed it sort of showed these
facilities popping up out of the desert
along with just a lot of high resolution
imagery such as what you'd see in google
earth
um honestly what we were struck by was
the scale
and the enduring nature of all of these
facilities and the fact that this
detention regime isn't something
temporary it's not
re-education where they get released
after 18 months
but it's a long term strategy of
detention
and in many ways in it and for many
people it's just removing them from
society because they were considered
to be too dangerous or perhaps too
uyghur or non-harm
is there anything the world can do i
mean the chinese government has
continued building more facilities even
as the international community has
made more and more noise about these
camps
i think what we look at now is probably
past the peak
in that it seems as though a decent
number of people genuinely have been
released into
different levels of residential demo
residential detention
and forced labor programs and that's not
ideal
but it's better than them being detained
in these prison systems and i think the
international pressure
has had a lot to do with that um
for the for the chinese authorities this
needs to make
economic sense in a way and they're
doing that through these forced labor
programs and
by manufacturing and that relies on the
rest of the world
buying these products so we hope that
this research into the enduring nature
and the sort of complete nature of this
detention
should teach western companies and
western
decision makers that basically buying
products from xinjiang and being
complicit in this system of detention
right is not okay nathan rooser
thank you